papa bear but um
you know he's a bucket full of joy
and a book
a bucket full of light
and if you could open up
if bill this next guy is a president you
opened it up remember in pulp fiction
when they opened up the briefcase that's
what you'd see oh a glowing light value
value yeah put in there by props
okay [ __ ] card
let me [ __ ] do the intro
what i didn't do anything yeah when i
said [ __ ] you probably you
kicked my foot i was swinging it's
[ __ ] hard cancelable
we talked about last week i go [ __ ]
that's okay right
all right so my point is this he was he
has an animated show called f is for
family would it be cloud for that
beautiful
it's my show right
it wasn't
i don't even know what he's doing right
now
this is so much fun um immoral compass
i'm on a show called immoral compass
dude you and vince vaughn need to be in
a movie together dude i'm telling you
the two of you guys on this on the
screen together was amazing thank you
give billboard a round of applause
is that all i had to do to end that
portrait was just compliment you yeah i
did it that was two minutes it was two
minutes it wasn't long enough um give
them another round of applause billboard
guys
yeah yeah you feel relaxed
yeah i'm fine
i don't know
you're just projecting all your
uncomfortableness on me i'm not doing
anything you are extra you're actually
like squirmy i know it's squirmy you are
let's go
let's calm down you're
right bill
thanks for being on the program again
and i really appreciate you spending the
time these are my options
what do you mean either over-the-top
energy
or he does like pbs voiceover yeah i'm
trying to find the right town with you
i'm having a good time i'm having a
blast
i had jim gaffigan on my podcast you got
uh yesterday all we did was trash each
other i don't even know how it happened
we were like talking comedy and like the
last 20 minutes we just trashed each
other
and it was only supposed to be 45
minutes long or so and it ended up being
an hour and 45 minutes we were having
such a good time really i'm enjoying all
of this i'm enjoying it as well showing
all your seated positions
you know if you would stop analyzing
right my bodily you know well you keep
doing it every eight seconds and you do
it very fast it's like distracting your
feet are flying around yeah
i saw an interview with ciao young fat
once yeah on e
back in the day
and um is that a skateboarder
what an e back in the day
you don't know
great skateboarder one of the original
x-gamers
was that a dictator or a director
on fat was a [ __ ] actor bro
and what how your fat was in [ __ ]
crouching tiger hidden dragon dog oh
they ran in the air
yeah on trees dog
and on sides of buildings
i love asian cinema but that's not one
of them
you don't like that movie it was all
right but the the running in the air was
just it was silly like the crowd i was
watching with would laugh all right you
should